كالاماري السواد هو من
القلائل الذين سمعوا شريط السيد.
هيرش جبنة الصدمة اللحظات الأخيرة خلصت
المقررة الخاصة للأمم المتحدة التي تقود
التحقيق في مقتله إلى
أن المملكة العربية السعودية كانت
مسؤولة عن
إعدام خارج نطاق القانون مع سبق الإصرار ، فقد
انتقدت ولي العهد السعودي
تعليقاته أمس وتنضم إلي الآن على
الهواء مباشرة من اسطنبول.  سمع ولي
العهد يقول إنه يتحمل المسؤولية الكاملة ،
فقد كان
ردك جيدًا على ردود الفعل عليه في
العشرينات الأولى من ذلك ، وهو يدرك ضمنيًا
أن هذا كان قتلًا للدولة وأن هذه
كانت جريمة قتل تتحمل الدولة
مسؤوليتها إلى حد.
أنه دولة وشبه رئيس دولة ،
وهذا شيء كنت أطلبه
على أساس النتائج التي توصلت إليها خلال
الأشهر الثلاثة الماضية ، وهو أمر
رفضته السلطات ، لذا فأنا سعيد إلى
حد ما بوجود اعتراف رسمي الآن
أن هذا
قتل دولة تتحمل المملكة العربية السعودية
مسؤوليته ثانياً رغم أن
المؤتمر يستلزم الكثير من
الألم  تباعد نفسه ، مما يخلق
حواجز وطبقات من الناس في
هذه المؤسسة بين القتل
وبينه ، وأن التباعد بالنسبة لي
لا يدعمه الدليل الذي
قدمته في تقريري ، العلاقة
بين هذا
القتل والمؤتمر وثيقة
بما فيه الكفاية.  أقرب بكثير في الواقع ، ولي
مستعد للتعرف عليها وفي بيان الصورة
لا يزال يفشل في إدراك
مسؤولياته الشخصية ، كل ما
يفعله هو ما يفعله رئيس
الدولة عادةً للابتعاد
عن التركيز الذي يدعي أنه
مرتفع  على مستوى المسؤوليات ولكن
يرفض الاعتراف بالمسؤولية الشخصية
عن القتل